los ex presidentes de bolivia y de
ecuador evo morales y rafael correa- ven
truncados sus deseos de regresar a
presentarse para cargos políticos en sus
respectivos países tras decisiones
judiciales en ambas naciones morales no
podrá aspirar a una banca en el senado y
correa quedó inhabilitado para
presentarse a la vicepresidencia
la atención social y política no se
detiene en belarús la líder opositora
malía kolésnikova fue detenida en la
frontera hacia ucrania cuando intentaba
abandonar su país su detención se suma a
las de miles de personas que se producen
ya hace semanas en medio de
manifestaciones que exigen la salida del
poder del presidente alexander
lukashenko
segundo día del juicio contra el
fundador de wikileaks julian assange
el periodista rechazó hacer su
extradición a eeuu después de que este
país ampliará en las últimas horas sus
acusaciones en esta segunda fase de
juicio tenemos reportes desde londres
buenos días saludamos a toda la
audiencia de france 24 muchísimas
gracias por acompañarnos y santiago
ariztía y comenzamos con noticias de
américa latina' nuevo revés legal para
el ex presidente de ecuador rafael
correa que queda ahora fuera de la
carrera para la vicepresidencia de su
país el ex mandatario no podrá hacer
candidato a la vicepresidencia de
ecuador en las elecciones de febrero de
2021 luego de que un tribunal mantuviera
la sentencia de ocho años de prisión e
inhabilitación para ejercer cargos
públicos por presuntamente haber
incurrido en el delito de cohecho en el
caso sobornos 2012 2016 la justicia
ecuatoriana desestimó un recurso que
buscaba anular esa sentencia
argumentando que no hubo irregularidades
durante el proceso en contra de correa
más temprano desde quitó nuestro
corresponsal gustavo ortega nos daba
detalles sobre esta causa por la que fue
sentenciado el exmandatario esto nos
decía
sí muy buenos días para ti el caso
sobrero 2012 2016 se origina en base a
una investigación periodística publicada
por dos portales digitales reportar la
fuente y el portal milhojas donde ellos
se publican correo electrónico recibido
por la ex asesora del ex presidente
rafael correa donde se desvela un correo
denominado receta verde este caso fue
conocido también como arroz verde o la
receta de arroz verde básicamente en
este correo adjunto se debe lavar una
detallada información sobre orígenes de
aporte financiero la trama se basa en
supuestos aportes financieros recibido
por parte de empresas transnacionales
aproximadamente 10 empresas
trasnacionales quienes liderados por la
presidencia de la república según la
fiscal general del estado se utilizaba
para recibir contratos de obra pública
esto fue una investigación que se
realizó por más casi 500 días de
investigación en lo que a origen
y también la ratificación de la
sentencia de ocho años al ex presidente
es rafael correa pero cuáles son las
implicaciones de este caso bueno
básicamente luego la ratificación de la
sentencia y la negación del recurso de
casación al ex presidente rafael correa
y un total de 18 implicado esto nunca
obstaculiza y de igual forma hace perder
los derechos políticos del ex presidente
rafael correa y de su ex vicepresidente
jorge glass reto básicamente no sólo
durante los próximos ocho años sino que
básicamente es la muerte política del ex
presidente rafael correa debe ser
recordar que luego de la reforma de la
constitución del año 2018 esto
básicamente establecía la muerte civil
de los ciudadanos implicados en delitos
de cohecho peculado y concusión por lo
cual la ex presidente rafael correa no
podrá participar en las próximas
elecciones del año 2021
masnoticias de américa latina' vamos
ahora a bolivia donde otro exmandatario
también ve truncado sus deseos de
regresar a la escena política es que la
justicia del país le prohibió al ex
presidente evo morales- postularse como
senador en las elecciones generales de
octubre un tribunal constitucional
rechazó la candidatura de morales como
senador por el estado de cochabamba y
deja firme de esta manera la resolución
que ya había sido adoptada en febrero
por el tribunal supremo electoral los
juristas argumentaron que el
exgobernante no cuenta con dos años
continuos de permanencia en bolivia
previo a los comicios ni con domicilio
en el país
recordemos que morales vive en argentina
desde noviembre tras haber renunciado a
la presidencia antes sospechas de fraude
electoral y en medio de denuncias de un
golpe de estado en su contra el ex
presidente aceptó la decisión y así lo
manifestaba
y nosotros acataremos a esa decisión
porque nuestro compromiso y prioridad es
que el pueblo salga de la crisis no
caeremos en ninguna provocación el
pueblo volverá a gobernarse a sí mismo
pacífica y democráticamente y en otras
noticias la líder opositora de belarús
hablamos de mariah kolésnikova fue
detenida en la frontera con ucrania
cuando intentaba abandonar el país la
agencia de noticias oficial informó que
la dirigente fue detenida por hacer este
trámite de manera ilegal kolésnikova
recordemos iba acompañada de dos
dirigentes políticos de quienes se cree
que si lograron cruzar la frontera los
tres hacen parte del consejo de
coordinación que pide una transferencia
pacífica del poder y esto en medio de
semana de manifestaciones
postelectorales contra el presidente
alexander lukashenko
aurora bayo tiene todos los detalles en
el siguiente informe
es la única de las tres líderes
opositores que siguen belarús marjah
kolésnikova líder de las protestas
contra el actual presidente fue detenida
mientras intentaba entrar en ucrania en
la madrugada del martes la líder de la
oposición en el exilio svetlana chicanos
kaia exigió la liberación inmediata de
su colaboradora a las figuras de la
oposición son retenidas bajo cargos
falsos intimidados y amenazados o
expulsados del país por completo ayer
mismo una de las líderes de las
protestas pacíficas mariah kolésnikova
fue secuestrada watch
el lunes por la mañana hombres no
identificados vestidos de negro
retuvieron a marjah kolésnikova y le
empujaron a un minibús marcado con la
palabra comunicaciones con rumbo
desconocido según informó su equipo de
campaña los dos aliados que la
acompañaban también miembros del consejo
coordinador para el traspaso pacífico
del poder habrían logrado cruzar la
frontera hacia ucrania por su parte la
agencia de noticias oficial informó
la dirigente opositora fue detenida en
la frontera cuando intentaba abandonar
ilegalmente belarús no hubo ningún
comentario de la policía de minsk
kolésnikova y otros miembros del equipo
de campaña del opositor víctor barbárico
anunciaron el mes pasado la creación de
un nuevo partido de oposición llamado
juntos crítica acérrima de lukachenko y
miembro del consejo de coordinación de
la oposición kolésnikova ha desempeñado
un papel importante en semanas de
manifestaciones masivas que acusan al
actual mandatario de amañar su
reelección las autoridades bielorrusas
ya han detenido a varios miembros de
este consejo e interrogado a otros
incluyendo a kolésnikova en una
investigación sobre un supuesto intento
de tomar el poder y el director del tour
de francia' hablamos de christian
prudhomme e dio positivo de kobe 19 pero
ningún ciclista ni miembro técnico
mecánico o médico de los equipos que
participan de la competencia se
encuentran contagiados en total unas 650
personas fueron sometidas al test en los
dos últimos días sobre
durante la jornada de descanso de este
lunes tal y como había establecido el
protocolo elaborado por los
organizadores en cooperación con la
unión ciclista internacional la
organización del tour determinó la
eventual descalificación de todo el
equipo en el que se confirmarán dos
casos positivos entre sus ciclistas y al
resto de los integrantes
las negociaciones post precise entre el
reino unido y la unión europea continúan
estancadas y londres ya está evaluando a
avanzar sin un acuerdo representantes
del reino unido y también de la unión
europea comenzaron este martes la octava
ronda de negociaciones para intentar
sellar un pacto comercial y también de
seguridad que debería entrar en vigor
una vez que finalice el periodo de
transición el próximo 31 de octubre
hasta ahora los encuentros no han
conseguido los avances esperados y las
tensiones se incrementaron ayer luego de
que el primer ministro británico boris
johnson mira un ultimátum para que
londres y bruselas lleguen a un acuerdo
para el 15 de octubre o de lo contrario
su país concretará el divorcio
definitivo
y hoy es además el segundo día del
juicio contra el fundador de wikileaks
julian assange el periodista rechazó
ayer su extradición a eeuu luego de que
este país ampliará durante las últimas
horas sus acusaciones nuestra
corresponsal en londres marcela
gutiérrez nos amplía desde el tribunal
donde se lleva a cabo esta segunda fase
del juicio
en el segundo día de audiencias en las
afueras del tribunal penal de old bailey
un grupo de manifestantes que simpatiza
con la causa de julian assange se dio
cita desde temprana hora este martes
para apoyar al fundador de wikileaks
pidiendo que se detenga su extradición a
eeuu y que lo liberen cuanto antes entre
otras de las consignas piden que el
periodismo no sea penalizado porque el
periodismo no es un crimen además
mientras el grupo de simpatizantes entre
los que se encuentran varios
latinoamericanos se encuentran afuera de
la corte adentro el fundador de
wikileaks se presenta por segundo día
consecutivo en este proceso de
extradición que se espera dure cuatro
semanas el día de hoy se espera la
comparecencia del
profesor en periodismo de la universidad
de maryland mcfield man quien en el día
de ayer no pudo presentar su
comparecencia vía remota desde eeuu
debido a que hubo problemas técnicos
a continuación avanzamos con otras
noticias destacadas hasta el momento en
france 24 en coincidencia con la
reanudación de las clases españa
superior los 500.000 casos de kobe 19 al
sumar más de 26.500 desde el pasado
viernes una media de más de 8 mil 250
por día en línea con los aumentos
diarios registrados en las últimas dos
semanas según cifras de la universidad
johns hopkins el país acumula argumentó
unos 525 mil 549 casos positivos
china celebró lo que denominaron la
derrota al brote del cob y 19 en una
ceremonia oficial y el mismo día en que
el país anunció que no quedan ya
contagios locales entre los casos
activos el gobierno condecoró a decenas
de trabajadores de la salud el
presidente jean jean ping señaló que la
suya en la primera gran economía en
volver al crecimiento
y argentina superó las 10.000 muertes
por el virus del cob y 19 en las últimas
24 horas se reportaron 271 excesos y
9.200 15 casos positivos con lo que las
cifras de casos totales superan ahora
los 488 mil y los fallecidos son al
momento 10 mil 129 según cifras del
ministerio de salud a nivel nacional se
estima un nivel de ocupación
hospitalario cercano al 60 por ciento
y tras casi dos años del asesinato de
hamás housing una corte de arabia
saudita conmutó las condenas a muerte de
varios de los presuntos implicados y dio
por cerrado el caso tras emitir condenas
de entre 7 y 20 años para ocho
individuos cuyos nombres no fueron
revelados la ex novia del periodista
desaparecido calificó a las sentencias
como una farsa y dijo que las preguntas
primordiales del caso continúan sin
tener una respuesta sebastián espinoza
tiene el informe
una corte saudita con moto las penas de
muerte en contra de cinco de los
presuntos asesinos de jamal ja sóc y en
estambul a cambio recibirán condenas de
20 años de cárcel otro fue sentenciado a
10 años de prisión y dos sospechosos más
a siete años los nombres de los
indicados jamás fueron revelados y la
prensa estatal comunicó el cierre del
caso de llama alias shops y ni lee las
sentencias suman en conjunto 124 años de
prisión para los culpables con la
decisión final el caso criminal tanto
público como privado ha cerrado
entretanto la familia del periodista
desaparecido y su expareja criticaron la
resolución está sentencia entregada hoy
por arabia saudita es una total burla la
justicia las autoridades sauditas están
cerrando el caso sin que el mundo sepa
la verdad sobre quién es el responsable
por el asesinato de jamal que lo planeó
que el orden o donde está su cuerpo
estas son las preguntas más básicas e
importantes que permanecen sin respuesta
alguna la comunidad internacional no
aceptará esta farsa
estoy más determinada que nunca en
luchar para lograr justicia para llamar
a la condena se unió la alta comisionada
de la onu para las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales hay escalas en estudio
el caso de cerca los cinco asesinos
fueron condenados a 20 años de prisión
pero los altos responsables que
organizaron y planearon el asesinato de
jamal chabti están libres en cuanto a la
responsabilidad del príncipe heredero
mohamed bin salman ésta no fue abordada
ya que desapareció el 2 de octubre de
2018 mientras visitaba el consulado de
arabia saudita en estambul para
solicitar documentos para poder contraer
matrimonio en turquía con hatice sanchis
las autoridades turcas revelaron que
jamal fue descuartizado en la sede
diplomática la cia concluyó que el
asesinato fue directamente ordenado por
el príncipe mohammed bin salman quien
nunca rindió cuentas ante la justicia y
esta manera llegamos al final de otra
emisión informativa pero quédense con
nosotros porque hay muchísimo más en el
resto de nuestra programación y
recuerden también que pueden seguir
ampliando estas noticias y conocer
muchas más en france24 punto com
[Música]